and i am running for governor
city of las vegas councilwoman michelle
fury announcing her run for the top job
in nevada government good afternoon and
thank you so much for joining us here at
four i'm christian costas good afternoon
to you i'm brian loftis now fiora said
she'd be holding a press conference with
her lawyer her attorney and then made
that surprise announcement the i-team's
vanessa murphy was there she's here now
in studio has more on the goals fiore
says she is setting for herself
and setting the stage here the majority
of supporters inside that room were not
wearing masks despite nevada's current
mask mandate and that's part of michelle
fiore's message she's against mask and
vaccine mandates it's important to note
the white house had previously
identified nevada as a hot spot for
kovid 19 transmission
i fight for our students
who get a mask taped on their face
fight for our teachers who are being
strangled by their unions fiore says as
governor she would ban mandated vaccines
on her first day the city of las vegas
councilwoman joined by supporters who
she says she's fought for and introduced
by chairman of the nevada republican
party michael mcdonald although the
campaign says mcdonald was there as a
friend not an endorsement fiori also
announcing she would ban critical race
theory in schools and audit the 2020
election that's despite nevada's
republican secretary of state saying
voter fraud was not widespread main
themes from the campaign don't expect
fiore to compromise and she's a fighter
fiori did not take reporter questions
instead her consultant did the campaign
also released this video of the
republican candidate toting a gun in the
desert the joe biden administration is
coming after me
and i asked fiori's consultant if she's
referring there to an fbi investigation
he says you could refer to any number of
accusations made against her by quote
the organized left end quote fiore has
been at the center of several
controversies coming up at five we're
going to take a look at them